foreign
ERS are brought to the public health
England staff who will be at the airport
having left one of those countries in
the last 21 days they will be asked a
series of questions through a
questionnaire and have their temperature
taken
thank you
if there is anybody who we have concerns
about that may be a risk to the Public's
Health then there are powers that can be
put in place to ensure that they are
taken to a hospital to be further
assessed and treated as necessary
the most important thing for us to do to
help resolve this problem is to work
with the country's concerns Sierra Leone
Guinea and Liberia as well as that there
is screening as people leave those
countries again the questionnaire and
the temperature check
foreign